was wäre wenn wir essen ohne Land
produzieren könnten mit etwas das
überall verfügbar ist das klingt zwar
echt verrückt aber ja es geht um Essen
aus Luft eine Firma aus Finnland
behauptet dass sie genau das kann also
richtiges Essen inklusive Proteinen
Fetten Ballaststoffen Vitaminen und
Mineralien alles was der Körper braucht
nur eben aus Luft aber kann das wirklich
sein oder verspricht die Firma da etwas
zu viel wenn das stimmt dann könnte die
Technologie dahinter eine Lösung für die
Nahrungsmittelknappheit sein man könnte
quasi überall und unabhängig von Klima
und Wetter Nahrung herstellen auch im
Weltall oder in der Wüste wie das alles
funktioniert wie realistisch die
Anwendung wirklich ist und natürlich
auch wie das dann schmeckt genau darum
geht's in diesem dr Watson
Video klingt komisch aber eigentlich
essen wir schon heute jeden Tag essen
aus Luft und zwar in Form von Pflanzen
die machen Luft für uns essbar indem Sie
mittels Fotosynthese CO2 aus der Luft
und Wasser mit Energie aus Sonnenlicht
zu Zucker verarbeiten andere Nährstoffe
und das Wasser werden durch die Wurzeln
aufgenommen man könnte also sagen in der
Luft ist schon alles vorhanden um
Nahrungsmittel herzustellen aber genau
diese Landwirtschaft wird uns in Zukunft
nicht mehr alle ernähren können also
müssen wir die Spielregeln ändern
weniger wegwerfen neue Pflanzensorten
effizientere Anbaumethoden und weniger
tierische Produkte oder wir ändern nicht
die Spielregeln sondern vor allem die
Spieler was ist mit neuen effizienteren
Organismen die Lebensmittel für uns
zusammenbauen und genau hier kommt eine
revolutionäre Idee ins Spiel die unsere
Landwirtschaft fast unabhängig von Land
machen könnte single cell Proteins die
heißen so weil sie aus einzähigen
Mikroorganismen bestehen also Hefen
Pilzen Algen oder Bakterien jeder
Mikroorganismus hat in der Herstellung
und Nutzung seine vor und nachteile
Algen brauchen relativ viel Fläche
werden aber schon lange genutzt Pilze
können Giftstoffe enthalten dafür sind
die Bioreaktoren leicht zu bauen um scps
herzustellen werden die Mikroorganismen
in einem Bioreaktor gezüchtet das ist
eine Art Kochtopf auf niedriger Hitze
der nach und nach die Zutaten in den
Topf gibt und sich selbst umrührt die
Zutaten sind in diesem Fall das Futter
für die Mikroorganismen inwiefern Luft
dieses Futter sein kann genau dazu
kommen wir gleich wenn die
Mikroorganismen eine Weile so
herangewachsen sind wird der Bakterien
oder algenlurry getrocknet und zu einem
Pulver verarbeitet herauskommt ein Mehl
oft mit über 50% Protein das entweder
direkt konsumiert an Tiere verfüttert
oder weiterverarbeitet werden kann das
riecht übrigens je nach Mikroorganismus
unterschiedlich Algen riechen z.B eher
fischig wie Bakterien scps riechen wurde
mit einer elektronischen Nase untersucht
und ist je nach Bakterium anders für
mich klingt das alles nach Zukunftsmusik
aber an diesen scps wird schon sehr
lange geforscht schon im ersten
Weltkrieg wurden scps als Tierfutter
verwendet mittlerweile sind sie aber
auch als menschliche Nahrung im Gespräch
denn eine finnische Firma stellt diese
single cell Proteins aus Luft her und
zwar unter den Namen solein übrigens
keine Werbung wie immer ist unsere
Berichterstattung hier unabhängig wir
haben nichts mit der Firma zu tun und
wie immer haben wir auch alle unsere
Quellen unten transparent in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt auch für
werden Bakterien gefüttert aber mit dem
Unterschied dass alle Hauptzutaten für
das Futter aus der Luft stammen also z.B
Kohlenstoff der in Form von CO2 in der
Luft enthalten ist das läuft dann so ab
zuerst wird Wasser mit der Elektrolyse
in Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff getrennt
der Bioreaktor füttert die Bakterien
dann mit winzigen Bläschen aus CO2
Wasserstoff und Nährstoffen wie Calzium
oder Phosphor das CO2 wird übrigens
mittels direct Air capture gewonnen also
direkt aus der Luft Luft gezogen und
wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt wie
diese Technologie dabei helfen kann den
Klimawandel aufzuhalten dann könnt ihr
euch unser Video dazu hier anschauen
entsteht das sollein also wirklich nur
aus Luft und Strom wie die Firma selbst
behauptet Trommelwirbel Jin die
Hauptinhaltsstoffe Kohlenstoff
Wasserstoff Sauerstoff und Stickstoff
sind aus der Luft ja aber es werden noch
ungefähr 5% weitere Nährstoffe
hinzugegeben wie Phosphor oder Calzium
die Pflanzen normalerweise aus dem
ziehen würden und am Strich lässt sich
also sagen dass mit dem Essen aus Luft
ist natürlich auch einfach gutes
Marketing trotzdem ist das Solin eine
mega Innovation weil es nicht auf
Ackerland angewiesen ist und besonders
wichtig unglaublich nachhaltig sein soll
das Unternehmen selbst behauptet dass
pro Gramm Protein nur 1% der Emissionen
von Fleisch und etwa 20% der Emissionen
von pflanzlichem Protein entstehen eine
Lebenszyklusanalyse der Universität
Helsinki hat das Solin mit anderen
proteinquell verglichen und zeigt die
Zahlen vom Unternehmen sind legit
allerdings nur dann wenn man nicht vom
finischen Strommix sondern von einem
optimierten Szenario mit lokaler
Wasserkraft und Wiederverwendung des
Abwassers ausgeht je nach Strom
unterscheiden sich die
Umweltauswirkungen nämlich echt stark
wie nah Solin jetzt gerade schon an
diesem Szenario dran ist das können wir
aber nicht genau sagen auch mit dem
Basisszenario ist Solin aber deutlich
nachhaltiger als alle tierischen
Proteinquellen erbsenprotein Schnitt in
der Studie aber im Punkt
treibhausgasemiss und acidifying
emissions darunter fallen z.B
Schwefeloxide besser ab auch Analysen zu
scps im allgemeinen klingen generell
vielversprechend auf der gleichen Fläche
können demnach zehn Mal so viel
Proteinen und mehr als doppelt so viele
Kalorien produziert werden denn die
Bakterien wachsen exponentiell ihre Zahl
verdoppelt sich in Minuten bis Stunden
das heißt sie wachsen viel viel
schneller als Pflanzen oder Tiere die
mindestens Monate brauchen bis sie
essbare Kalorien werden wenn ihr vorerst
beim herkömmlichen Essen bleiben und
wissen wollt welche Nährstoffe da drin
sind dann kann ich euch übrigens jazio
sehr empfehlen die App zerlegt euer
Essen quasi in seine Bestandteile und
gibt an wie viel Kohlenhydrate Fette und
Proteine ihr zu euch nehmt aber nicht
nur das auch welche Mineralstoffe
Vitamine und andere Nährstoffe darunter
sind wird euch hier angezeigt was bringt
mir das damit kann man z.B Kalorien
zählen ich selber habe mich die längste
Zeit meines Lebens als zu dick
betrachtet und darunter litt mein
Selbstwertgefühl und noch viele andere
Dinge bis ich dann im Januar 2021
beschlossen habe abzunehmen gemacht habe
ich das mit Kalorienzählen ja das passt
nicht zu jedem aber bei mir hat das sehr
gut funktioniert weil es eine sehr
akkurate und wissenschaftliche Methode
ist um abzunehmen das passt zu mir aber
das muss wie gesagt nicht zu jedem
passen und ein gesunder Lebensstil mit
Sport und der richtigen Ernährung ist
für den Erfolg mindestens genauso
wichtig wie die richtige Menge an
Kalorien jazio hat mir damals erlaubt
über 16 kg abzunehmen dafür habe ich nur
angegeben wie viel ich wiege und wie
viel ich wiegen möchte daraus berechnet
jazu dann wie viel Kalorien man jeden
Tag zu sich nehmen sollte dank der
großen Datenbank könnt ihr dann einfach
alles was ihr den Tag über esst per
Barcode einscannen oder händisch
eintragen ich habe mir dann auch
ziemlich schnell jazio pro geholt weil
es da noch mal mehr Features gibt z.B
intervallfasten was mir persönlich auch
noch mal viel geholfen hat was ich aber
damals nicht hatte war ein Rabattcode
von Dr Watson über 50% für ein Jahr über
den ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung bekommt ihr jazio pro
für ungefähr 2 € im Monat und außerdem
auch meine persönlichen fünf Tipps zum
Abnehmen aber nun zurück zum Protein des
Tages und womöglich auch zur Ernährung
der Zukunft heißt das dass wir also in
ein paar Jahren alle unser Mittagessen
aus proteinpulvereimern Löffeln nein die
Firma dahinter stellt sich das eher so
vor solein soll in allen möglichen
Gerichten eingesetzt werden z.B als
Fleisch Ei oder milchalternative in
Getränken oder als proteinbost in Nudeln
pur soll es nussig leicht umami und
buttrig schmecken aber sehr mild das
bedeutet es lässt sich in vielen
Produkten einsetzen und genau das ist
der Plan denn Solin soll Business to
Business an andere Firmen verkauft
werden die es dann in ihren Produkten
wiederum einsetzen einen Vorgeschmack
gab es in Singapur im Mai bei einem
fünfgänge tasting mit Solin in jedem
einzelnen Gang die Gäste vom tasting
sind auf jeden Fall beeindruckt aber die
Gerichte wurden natürlich auch von
Profiköchen zubereitet und die Gäste
wurden halt auch von der Firma
eingeladen sind also eventuell nicht so
unabhängig vielleicht sollte man mich
mal einladen ich werde auf jeden Fall
viel unabhängiger was höre ich da sind
das schon die ersten wütenden
Kommentarschreiber die von ekligen
Bakterien sprechen die im Bioreaktor
Proteine herstellen total unnatürlich
okay fair enough ist das alles überhaupt
gesund wichtige Frage die Firma dahinter
sagt selbst dass keine gesundheitlichen
Nachteile durch den Konsum entstehen
können das wollen wir aber natürlich
nicht einfach nur so stehen lassen
sondern auch selbst überprüfen haben
aber leider keine unabhängige Studie
gefunden die sich konkret mit solleinen
auseinandersetzt in Studien die sich
generell mit scps auseinandersetzen wird
aber auf einen Nachteil hingewiesen scps
können nicht unbedingt müssen aber
können ungesunde Stoffe wie Toxine
enthalten außerdem haben sie einen sehr
hohen Gehalt an Nukleinsäure die mit
Nierensteinen in Verbindung gebracht
wird ob und welche unerwünschten Stoffe
enthalten sind ist aber abhängig davon
welche Einzeller verwendet werden es
gibt also durchaus welche bei denen das
nicht so ist außerdem können diese
Stoffe häufig durch weitere Prozesse
entfernt werden wenn die Firma dahinter
sich darum kümmert gibt es also
eigentlich keinen Grund anzunehmen dass
Solin ungesund ist im Gegenteil es
liefert alle essentiellen Aminosäuren
und ist zusätzlich noch mit weiteren
Nährstoffen angereichert es könnte also
tatsächlich helfen den Welthunger zu
bekämpfen insbesondere durch
hochwertigere Proteine und auch für die
Raumfahrt wäre das eine potenziell
bahnbrechende Technologie auf Missionen
im All brauchen Astronauten gesunde
Nahrung die aber nicht viel wiegen darf
darum arbeitet die Firma an einem Mini
Bioreaktor der die die Crew versorgen
könnte bisher ist der aber noch zu
schwer darum wird Stahl durch leichtere
Materialien ersetzt in ein paar Jahren
könnte es aber soweit sein dann wäre der
minireaktor
einsatzbereit und hier auf der Erde
bisher gibt es das Pulver noch nicht zu
kaufen nur in Singapur ist es überhaupt
schon zugelassen und selbst dort gibt es
solinprodukte bisher nur bei besonderen
Aktionen wie diesem erwähnten tasting
das liegt daran dass die Pilotanlage in
Finnland nur 1 kg Solin am Tag
produziert aber gerade wir wir an der
Factory Zero one gebaut in der im
nächsten Jahr die kommerzielle
Produktion starten soll das heißt wir
müssen abwarten wie gut es mit der
Skalierung läuft soloin kann also
tatsächlich Teil einer Antwort auf die
globalen Herausforderungen sein es gibt
noch sehr viel zu tun insbesondere mit
Blick auf die Skalierung und die
unabhängige Forschung dazu aber die Idee
dass wir in einigen Jahren mit ein paar
Löffeln sollein quasi jedes
Nahrungsmittel proteinreicher gestalten
können das ist schon ziemlich cool und
dass wir in Zukunft unabhängig von Klima
Wetter und Pflanzen Essen herstellen
können und dass ein paar Bakterien in
lebensfeindlichen Regionen leben möglich
machen das ist genial und das könnte
Menschenleben retten ich bin schon sehr
gespannt wie es mit dieser Technologie
weitergeht wenn ihr hierzu auf dem
Laufenden bleiben wollt dann abonniert
am besten den Kanal wir werden auf jeden
Fall ein Update Video dazu machen und
bis es soweit ist bleibt neugierig
bleibt gesund
euerstreck